[Musique]
avant de commencer je vous rappelle que
je suis en tournée avec mon spectacle le
spectacle de la maturité dans toute la
france même arrangé en suisse en
belgique et au québec
toutes les dates sont affichées ici
grâce à la magie du montage j'ai hâte de
vous y voir pour unir place dans les
script sion ça y est je fais partie des
24 % des français qui ont déjà fait un
régime dans leur vie un régime
amaigrissant et j'ai perdu
tenez vous bien douce qui c'est faux en
fait j'ai perdu 7 kilos mais andré jeu
très content c'est exactement mon
objectif donc tout va bien m de là ce
régime sait pas pourquoi je l'annoncé
frère ait eu un article dans la presse
c'est à dire que là le monde entier et
pendues à ce régime
bon je suis sûr que vous voulez voir le
résultat
ok tu commences à un régime tu te mets à
dire les phrases de régime vous savez du
pain de seigle quelqu'un veut des
graines du pain complet
non mais moi j'ai les au louvre cette
famille ou du pain de foin c'est quoi
ton imc toi moi c'est 49 ça avance qua
non mais là je suis pas allé y est là
j'ai un max de merde en moi tu vois ton
dessert vin j'ai même pas envie je n'ai
plus envie de sucre depuis que je fais
un régime
j'ai une énergie si je pense plus vite à
tout et plus agile quoi dans ma manière
de vivre alors au menu on a 20 g de
lipides 20 grammes de glucides des
protéines un village ne pèse avec les
vêtements là ça compte pas est-ce que je
peux avoir ça s'il vous plaît mais sans
les frites et sans avocat et la sauce à
part d'un petit ramequin et se passe à
l'est et se sont revenus donc j'aurai un
premier dîner terminé
c'est comme le petit déj maintenant dans
trésor t on plus commencer maintenant
là j'ai commencé à un vrai régime parce
que avant j'avais déjà fait des régimes
mais un peu dans ma tête quoi tu vois le
genre de régime dont je parle bonjour
alors je vais prendre un big mac un
filet o fish une grande frite 9 nuggets
et un coca mais zéro par contre parce
que je suis au régime lors chacun a sa
propre raison de faire un régime moins
clairement c'était un peu de tout
mélanger
surtout que je pense avoir développé ce
qu'on appelle une couvade alors ce truc
savent pas qu'est ce qu'une couvade en
gros quand un couple va avoir un enfant
parfois le père est tellement en soutien
psychologique avec la mère qui peut
avoir le ventre qui gonfle lui aussi à
sofia pas d'entendre d'angoissé plutôt
de l'épisode du chocolat et moi j'ai eu
ça dans la rue on me faisait attendre
c'est une fille ou un garçon là c'est
faux j'ai inventé ce anecdotes ça ne
s'est jamais produit je jure ça paraît
ouf mais ça existe vraiment ce truc et
je crois même que ça peut aller encore
plus loin
regardez je checke vite fait sur
wikipédia troubles psychologiques se
manifestant de manière psychosomatiques
l'apparition de prolactine [ __ ]
hormones de la lactation
l'homme peut produire du lait par les
tétons que c'est ouf comment le cerveau
peut changer ton corps quoi passer 30
ans à ton corps change n'assimile pas du
tout pareil
les aliments t'as quand j'étais petit
j'étais un vrai mec je n'arrivais pas à
prendre de la masse je pouvais manger
des burgers du chocolat de la fondue au
red bull ça ne faisait rien maintenant
je la pensais à l'effet de chaque
aliment sur mon corps à temps mais si je
mange
je vais sans doute avoir des brûlures
d'estomac des ballonnements des gaz
diarrhées du mal à digérer tu m'as la
donne hakem tumeur mais trois ballack à
l'ofec quant à un petit peu de bide bon
c'est chiant mais c'est pas très grave
qui a du coup les gens se permettent des
vannes sans aucune pression quoi
histoire vraie une fois après un
spectacle sur scène une dame du public
est venu me voir
pas de spectacle c'est vraiment super
par contre le ventre sur scène pas ouf
merci pour vos retours en tout cas de
ria quand tu fais un régime
tout à coup tout le monde se prend ton
coach toi déjà tu galères tu fais des
efforts depuis des semaines il ya
toujours un mec qui trouve un truc à
dire allez mon petit plaisir d'ajourner
des amendes et une pomme tu sais que 10
amende égale un stickers gueule il ya
sans doute plein de ses conseils que son
bras prendra mais quand tu es dans
l'effort du régime des fois tout d'un
coup c'est un peu dur à digérer
bon il existe plein de régimes
différents c'est infini il existe même
le régime palais au concept c'est de
manger de la même manière que les hommes
préhistoriques plus précis je regarde
sur wiki je vous dis moi je dis oui
keeway il est en revanche les produits
issus de l'agriculture et de l'industrie
agroalimentaire comme les céréales et là
bas que ça pouvait avoir des bienfaits
de manger comme ça quoi cassiopée
j'avais pas plus d'un régime paléo en
fait ben moi non plus chez les aa je
tiens mais c'est complètement faux tap
comme régine connu il ya aussi du camp
concept c'est que tu mange de la viande
quasiment tout le temps on voit le 12h30
ont coulé dans le café le matin quand tu
fais un régime il ya des pièges
impossible de manger une seule si oui le
bonjour l'orthophoniste ouais c'est pour
une consultation impossible de manger
une chips essayé mais qu il prend encore
une juste une vrai que deux
les mecs une de plus tout petit dernier
relais chose qui ne se produit pas avec
les poireaux toi tu parles pas passons
pour savoir si un truc fait grossir
c'est très simple si c'est bon ça fait
grossir c'est ma théorie alors la mecque
des hommes et je te coupe les légumes
quand tu sais bien les cuisiner il ya
une vraie saveur c'est faux c'est bon
mais moins bon qu'est ce qu'il ya de
meilleur qu'une frite des plans
commentaire [ __ ] j'ai une dalle
quand tu fais un régime parfois il fait
ce qu'on appelle le fameux craquage
aussi appelé le petit mil
c'est à dire que tout à coup tu craques
tu manges comme un ouf n'importe quoi
mais une seule fois dans la semaine je
peux dire mon pote que quand à manger
des brocolis à l'eau toute la semaine ta
pizza tu la manges pas pareil après si
tu fais 2 3 craquage par jour passent
pas du tout un régiment fait bon je suis
sûr que vous voulez voir le résultat
ok
[Musique]
à quoi bon allez je vous montre vraiment
[ __ ] le corps le plus banal d'europe
ouais c'est très impressionnant ouais
mais en vrai comparer la photo d'avant
je vous jure c'est un truc de ouf
j'avais clairement le même corps que
buzz dans les arbres et de l'espace
bompard au fouet bon alors toi vers dire
bonjour à la dame écrit c'est ouf je
vous montre avant de me dire ce que vous
en pensez mais sans me taussat exagéré
pour la vidéo oh mais bon ça c'est un
vrai bien vu très largement de la
résultat maintenant on va se trouve que
tu as perdu douce et que c'était lui cet
été mais qui manque du muscle à la
fourmi
tu as grandi en feu
et moi je fais ma vidéo à poil j'en ai
plus rien à [ __ ] attention cette vidéo
n'est pas du tout fait pour vous inciter
à faire un régime pas du tout dans la
vie on n'est pas obligé de faire un
régime
même si la santé c'est important chacun
fait ce qu'il veut ya pas de normes
physiques tous les corps sont beaux on
le dira jamais assez c'est la vérité le
plus important c'est de s'accepter comme
on est et si vous vous lancez dans un
régime ne fait pas seul à entourez vous
de gens qui s'y connaissent vraiment des
gens de confiance des proches tête par
exemple votre médecin peut être même si
vous avez les moyens un ou une
nutritionniste bref c'est pas un truc
qui se fait n'importe comment
et évidemment le meilleur conseil que
vous donner c'est de ne pas suivre mes
conseils
ça c'est le meilleur conseil en parlant
de prendre de la masse j'ai envie de
passer à l'étape supérieure et de me
mettre sérieusement au sport et pour me
motiver je vais appeler ici maintenant
sur ce plateau qui n'est pas du tout un
plateau quelqu'un qui pour moi être
sorte de guide spirituel le numéro un en
termes de muscles si je vous dis petit
d'inde
si je vous dis boom un maximum de pouce
bleus pour tirer une cheville il fera
chanter des airs normative ailleurs si
vous remercie d'être là mais qu'avait
merci à toi de l'habitation en tout cas
en plus je viens du sud de la france
pourrait avoir
mais oui de la conterie toulouse est
injuste a peut-être toulouse heures on
touche une petite vidéo sur le régime
eh bien tu as concert régime j'ai
commencé un régime j'ai perdu fabien 7
kg bravo tu sais pas dit c'est que moi
j'ai fait une sorte de petit kuvan
d'accord suite avec bruce willis que tu
étais pas je suis papa j'ai toujours aux
normes est dans l'entente de laisser
aller où tu te dis bon bah vas-y vie que
tout le monde est gros dans la maison va
falloir essayer je mangeais pas bien tu
manges
mal je mange un mode vraiment aucune
limite moi pas de sport par activité
physique passeport clairement pas un bel
exemple en fait d'accord pas tout si je
prendrais tu prends les matchs pour les
votes alors après il ya mille et une
méthode pour mincir pour faire des
sports et où certains disent qu'il faut
commencer par le sport est finalement
pas faire forcément de régime ça dépend
ça dépend entre nous soit tu commences
par le sport et dans ce cas qui permet
de manger ce que tu veux à côté soit tu
commences par l'alimentation et à manger
bien et correctement et le sport peut
venir après année pour pouvoir chaque
cas est différent et chaque année
objectif aussi différents exactement
mais moi à jamais quand il aurait avalé
à ses justes de l'or qui sortent juste
un petit mot sur ton ta tenue d'accord
le gars tous les vêtements sinsheim
ça ça doit tant que ça les chaussettes
sont plus chers on vas tu as fait une
vidéo ensemble à quelques temps oui je
te rappelle on avait fait une vidéo la
salle de muscu ce moment tu pousses qui
font pitié contracter les muscles pour
développer la masse tu vois comme ça
apparemment ça pas trop traumatisant
photo a d'ailleurs fini à vidéo et tu
m'avais dit thibault s'était ya quatre
ans je commence à l'usc eu ce soir
ouais et du coup on fait on va faire le
bilan quatre ans la plus tard moi je
suis sûr que j'ai arrêté trois fois
depuis vraiment je n'ai pas du tout
pendant neuf mois les couches une merde
voilà si vous ne soit pas une vidéo en
votre journée est ce qu'on fait en effet
années 80 pour le changement de
vêtements
c'est parti magnifique es magnifique
raté bull a offert merci vraiment lente
dahmane est ce que je peux proposer de
juger mon corps d'accord d'entités comme
ça y'a quand même temps là ça c'était
l'été dernier sur une page on voit une
nette différence au niveau des poignées
d'amour je trouve que tu as perdu si
cette partie là on n'en veut ni sarine
amour t'es pas gras ce niveau là et ça
c'est super important
ensuite au niveau de la bouée on peut
faire quelque chose contre acte le
ventre là bas je contracte en fait déjà
la leaf hockey non c'est bien regarde là
on voit avec l'ombre là on voit les
abdos qui sont là ne se font ce nom
envoyez abdallah ii sous l'oeil sur la
com à faire c'est qu'on va pousser en
fait ce qu'il ya là la grèce callas et
au peuple a montré dans d'épais
crispante
parce que c'est le seul concept une
sorte de liposuccion mais exactement
enchères
respire ça que tu terme en optimist et
ça mais quand j'ai pas entendre je crois
en toi normal tu vois que tu faisais un
régime est en train de perdre du poids
mais est ce que tu es un objectif à long
terme et à court terme
ben moi je craque on nous utilise fils
est atteint c'est à dire je suis à 75
hockey soit 4 kg je connais même pas
ah ouais ouais j'suis 115 kilos répartis
de manière différente logistique et de
bagdad encore en fait très très bien
sans la scène du sud c'est gratuit ça va
être compliqué c'est compliqué c'est
possible en deux ans trois ans déjà tu
peux avoir un très très beau résultat
tous milieux longuement huawei c'est
long mais c'est la réalité tu vois
j'étais préparé un petit programme
d'entraînement à faire à la maison au
poids du corps pas besoin de matériel
toutes les personnes qui regardent la
vidéo pourront eux aussi le faire chez
eux ça c'est génial
faites le en même temps que nous si vous
voulez on va s'amuser peut-être que
c'est parti pour google
bon bah c'est parti pour la petite
séance de gym je suis un petit peu
angoissé pas vous mentir on lance la
musique libre de droit entre team
tranquillement et or se mettre en jambes
aujourd'hui en fin d'entraînement 45 15
ça veut dire quoi faire 45 secondes
d'effort et 15 secondes de récupération
va faire du jumping jack tu vas prendre
des filles étaient boire ouais comme ça
hop le décor
ok on va se mettre au sol comme ça comme
ça comme ça et comme ça au hockey
[Musique]
allez allez tous en blanc c'est derrière
chez moi je suis vraiment très bien fait
d'accord john abbott est une puissance
au qui veut tout a bien failli ne pas te
plaît donc on va faire des pompes répond
que ça peut être compliqué de faire cet
exercice là donc on va les faire niveau
facile sur le genou à la maison j'ai
déjà fait 30 ans des petites pompes sur
les genoux et même là haut mais
lendemain j'ai vraiment les muscles pas
les courbatures
les muscles arracher une semaine allez
gore qui l'aimé comme ça et là hop on
descend voilà quand ceux ci au sol et on
on va se mettre au sol et on va faire
des crunch et tu reviens comme ça ok ont
fait leur cheval à au premier projet
inquiète pas et comme ça il est comme ça
allez on va travailler les fessiers mais
toi comme moi comme ça les bras le long
du corps et tu vas venir lever comme ça
françois imbeau sexuelle 1 les gens ne
fait pas un screenshot en repas on va
commencer à faire du albert pisé c'est
la moitié d'un bear physique mais comme
ceux ci et hop tu fais que le saut non
c'était bizarre mais comme exercice
même moi je dormais dans voisines sont
plus des gains enfin le superman dont
les assises annulé ok superman donc on
se met au sol comme ceux ci et l'arc
fera on va travailler
le taux tu as le vt20 mettez moi et tu
relâches aller chez partir osmos holtz
nouvelle thema aussi à tous tes fesses
au niveau du cul exactement être peut le
ranger ta tête sur le sol et on fait
comme ça
les ciseaux en jeu tous nos supports
[Musique]
il a récemment lié à l'or finit en
beauté aux affaires du monde des bars à
lait normal c'est parti des gens comme
ça et autres je regarde devant toi fier
et comme ça comme la fatalité partie par
l'appétit so let's riquet bravo tu vas
tu es tu allé jusqu'au bout je suis fier
de toi c'est pas facile
comment tu t'es senti la demi-part à
l'aise au début à la fin ouais c'est
faux la colo pas l'air très bien cette
très vieille année puis à tous et ce
n'était pas facile et pour moi j'étais
très très bien déroulé c'est un beau
potentiel
j'adorais le exercice a annulé sa
marraine pourquoi tu mangeras pas je
suis clairement que les époques les
semis petit con pas de quoi bomber shirt
à l'aise dans les popotes c'est très
très la banane c'est super les bananes
aussi à l'acte a fait exactement ce que
je voulais c'est à dire me destroy et
c'est ça que cherchait en fait tu
laboures ça si tu as besoin un jour si
toi tu t'ennuies sa soeur instructeur de
lui en fait non merci beaucoup monsieur
quoi notre colosse école va partager en
tout cas merci à toi je vais le refaire
à la maison pour de vrai fait chaud la
maison aussi dites-moi ce que ça résiste
et fait du mal à parler non pas d'où tu
fais un match d'abord été interdit à la
nage
on va tous les muscles de la bio ne
marche plus n'hésitez pas la refaire
chez vous aussi c'est un peu le butin de
partager ce truc là exactement ces
prépas une vidéo retour sur sa chaîne à
ce n'est pas dans les changes en fait je
te propose norman une petite vidéo
tranquille sur ma chaîne youtube d'une
vidéo dessin ben vas-y kah walla
histoire d'être tranquille finir la
finir l'après-midi de façon positive et
des mecs leurs achats ont fini la vidéo
sur ce mot culte que je rêvais de faire
avec toi exactement n'oubliez pas que
vous êtes les meilleurs bolt
[Musique]